unsere welt steckt voller unglaublicher
phänomene wusstet ihr zum beispiel dass
es mehr möglichkeiten gibt dieses
kartendeck zu mischen als die erde atome
hat ihr glaubt mir nicht dann bleibt
dran das hier ist ein standard 52
kartendeck und ich habe gerade mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit von annähernd 100
prozent eine karten reihenfolge
erschaffen die es noch nie zuvor in der
geschichte der menschheit gegeben hat
und die ist auch höchst wahrscheinlich
nie wieder geben wird
52 karten das ist eigentlich gar nicht
so viel wie ist es möglich dass noch nie
jemand zufälligerweise genau diese
reihenfolge der stadt
naja möglich ist es schon nur ist es
unglaublich unwahrscheinlich denn es
gibt mehr möglichkeiten diese 52 karten
anzuordnen
als sterne im beobachtbaren teil unseres
universums kippt
unser planet die erde besteht grob
geschätzt aus zehn hoch 50 atom das sind
eine menge aber immer noch viel weniger
als es unterschiedliche reihenfolgen
gibt dieses kleine kartendeck zu mischen
denn das sind 18 10 167
unterschiedlicher reihenfolge
das ist eine riesige zahl ist so eine
unglaublich große zahl dass man sie mit
den menschlichen verstand einfach nicht
begreifen kann
aber ich versuche trotzdem mal euch
zumindest ansatzweise das ausmaß dieser
gigantischen zeit klar zu machen
stellt euch vor ihr müsst ein mal pro
sekunde dieses kartendeck und bei jedem
match vorgang entsteht eine neue
reihenfolge der einfachheit halber gehen
wir mal davon aus dass wir nicht zweimal
die gleiche reihenfolge mission was in
der realität gerade gegen ende relativ
oft passieren dürfte aber egal wie lange
braucht ihr also wenn ihr jede sekunde
eine neue kombination herstellt um
einmal jede kombination zu erhalten ein
paar tage ein paar jahre
euer ganzes leben ein leben reicht dafür
leider nicht aus selbst wenn jeder
mensch der jemals geboren wurde von den
ersten höhlenmenschen bis zu uns heute
jede sekunde seines lebens damit
verbracht hätte karten zu mischen
hätten wir heute nicht mal den bruchteil
eines prozents jeder kombination
also wie lange braucht man wirklich
stellt euch vor ihr mischt tag ein tag
aus jeder sekunde eine neue kombination
und einmal alle milliarden jahre kommt
jemand zu euch auf die erde und nimmt
ein sandkorn mit ein einziges danach
müsst ihr weiter und weiter und wieder
nach einer milliarde jahre kommt jemand
und nimmt ein zweites land konnte das
spiel geht solange weiter bis ihr
wirklich alle sandkörner jeder wüste
jedes strandes jedes sandkastens leer
gemischt habt dann kommt wieder jemand
vorbei und gibt euch einen cent
netterweise bringt auch den ganzen land
wieder mit und füllt die erde wieder auf
und fuhr ihr könnt weiter mission jede
sekunde eine neue kombination für den
spottpreis von einer milliarde euro
könnt euch dann beim verkäufer eures
vertrauens ein einzelnes blatt papier
kaufen dann könnt ihr endlich auch hin
zu mischen wenn ihr einen papier turm
gekauft habt der bis zur sonne leicht
entschuldigung habe ich gesagt ein
papier touren ich meinte 24 millionen
es ist wirklich erstaunlich was in so
einem mickrigen kleinen weg mit 52
karten steckt also wenn ihr das nächste
mal ein kartendeck mischt dann fühlt
euch besonders denn ihr seid mit
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit der
einzige mensch der jemals diese
kombination an karten gemischt hat und
jede mission wird ein kartendeck
zwischen ist also wirklich reiner zufall
oder nicht
nun nicht wenn man an eine
deterministische universum glaubt den
der wissenschaft muss ein experiment
unter denselben bedingungen immer
dieselben ergebnisse hervorrufen
zwei teilchen reagieren immer auf
dieselbe art und weise die kleinsten
bausteine der materie die wir im moment
kennen sind crocs es gibt sechs reguläre
und sechs antiquar chst und auf diesen
zwölf teilchen kann man eigentlich alles
bauen was wir kennen jedes atomen jedes
elektronen alles wenn man jetzt in einem
geschlossenen system wie position und
geschwindigkeit eines jeden teilchens
kennt dann kann man berechnen wie diese
teilchen miteinander reagieren werden
und was passieren wird
man kann die zukunft berechnet für die
dauer von einer sekunde reicht es
vielleicht auf diesen raum ihr als
abgeschlossenes system zu betrachten
könnte man also berechnen oder
simulieren wie ich mission werde wie
schnell sich meine hand bewegt wie viel
karte nicht greifen werde und wohin ich
sie genau verteilen werde
schenkt man laplace albert einstein und
vielen anderen wissenschaftlern glauben
dann ja ist das so dann ist alles
bereits vorher bestimmt gedanken und
gefühle sind nur chemie berechenbare und
vorhersehbare chemie einen freien willen
gibt es nicht denn wir sind nicht einmal
maschinen oder dinge wir sind einfach
nur einen haufen kleiner teile die den
gesetzen der physik folgend aufeinander
reagieren ziemlich deprimierend wenn man
darüber nachdenkt aber das war die
gängige meinung vieler wissenschaftler
bis vor ca 100 jahren hat sich seitdem
eine menge getan
die verrückte welt der quantenphysik hat
uns gezeigt dass es dinge gibt die nicht
vorhersehbar sind
das ist zeichen gibt die auch bei exakt
gleichen bedingungen nicht immer gleich
reagieren
hier sind wahrscheinlichkeiten die regel
manchmal reagiert ein teilchen so und
manchmal ebenso und manchmal verändern
teilchen sogar wie sie sich verhalten
je nachdem ob jemand gerade hinschaut
oder ob sie unbeobachtet sind vielleicht
steckt ja in diesem kleinen
wahrscheinlichkeiten unser freier wille
und nachdem butterfly effect werden die
kleinsten änderungen im quanten bereits
zu großen änderungen auf molekularer
ebene und verändern schließlich unsere
wahrnehmbare realität also wenn ihr euch
das nächste mal zum normal zu eintönig
oder vorhersehbar fühlt dann denkt daran
dass ihr aus einer unglaublichen anzahl
von unberechenbaren teilchen besteht ein
riesiger haufen zu fall und
individualität und jetzt würde ich gerne
von euch wissen was ist das zufällig
sste und unberechenbarste dass ihr kennt
schreibt sie wohnen in die kommentare
und ansonsten würde ich mich darüber
freuen wenn ihr das video mit euren
freunden teilt und beim nächsten mal
wieder einschaltet danke führst du schon